hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video and as the title states are gonna
be talking about how to get the new
Christmas loot or the frost wind fall
loot from this new festival on for honor
we're gonna talk about how to get it the
fastest so let's get right into this so
I know all of you watch this video
because you want to get that new gear
and trust me who would I mean so do i
this event comes with event exclusive
items like battle off its ornaments
color palettes and for the first time
ever exclusive weapons for each
character the only issue is that there's
so much gear you have to go through now
with the inclusion of weapons it's so
tough to get the stuff that you want for
your main the game will still give you
gear for the DLC characters even if you
don't have them and all that gear is
only available for the event and if you
don't get it before the event ends you
won't be able to get it again until they
do it next year so that's why I decided
to make this first thing we need to do
is find the fastest game-mode to
maximize the amount of gear we get so
basically all the battle modes are out
elimination skirmish Dominion and
tribute are out since they take too long
and the PvP playlist is out because you
could still earn rewards against bots
but the only game mode you cannot earn
rewards in for bots is P Vai in duel so
the next best thing we have is brawl
brawl takes the quickest time and it
spots it's super easy so I decided to
play five random brawl matches with a
random person and the times I got were
203 206 157 214 and 210 to complete the
match I added all of these totals up and
divided them by 5 since there is 5
numbers and I got the average of about
206 so about 2 minutes and 6 seconds to
complete each match as an average
obviously this is going to be a bit
different for everybody because you may
or may not have a good teammate and you
may also have to fight level 3 bots so
there's tons of variables that you can't
include because it's too random so then
I took 2 minutes in 6 seconds and put it
into actual seconds which is 126 then I
took it into an hour to see how many
times we can get items in an hour took
the 60 minutes and put that into seconds
which is 3600 divided 3600 by 126 and
got 28.5 so you could either say 28
around it 229 doesn't really matter so
you're roughly going to get 28 to 29
items an hour now I didn't include the
wait time in this in between matches
because once again it's different every
time the teammate may leave or he may
queue up again with you who knows it's
just too
to include so I just stuck it with that
so it's a recap once again play brawl AI
with a buddy or play alone and decimate
the bots and get tons of loot from it if
you want to include wait times you might
get about 24 items an hour and that is
an incredible amount for how much there
is in this game
I also remember to use your mane for the
event because the event exclusive weapon
parts will only drop from the character
that you play but anyway guys that's
going to be the end of the video if you
did enjoy please sure to give it a like
if you found this video also helpful
please sure to give it a like and why
not while you're at it hit the subscribe
button takes a couple seconds I talked
about the for honor news the leaks the
information the discussion all that type
of stuff before honor while you're at it
hit the bell right next to do because
they notified of all of my video streams
and community posts you never miss an
upload of mine my two most recent videos
gonna be popping up on screen if you
didn't see those and with that guys hope
you have a great rest of your weekend
and peace out